[Music]
congratulations this has to be uh
surreal for you this is one of the most
successful movies of all time that's a
very big title yeah it's uh it's very
exciting and we worked very hard on the
movie so to have it finally come out and
people actually come out and see it was
very very nice more than a few people
came out well yeah
they wanted a platform released
originally and kind of slowly but i was
like let's just hit them full force
let's release worldwide it made 800
gillion dollars 800 that's the final
number uh that's a real word that's come
out they invented a new number they
didn't it was kind of crazy now you've
known for a long time you were quite
young but you know you knew since you
were a little kid that you want to be an
actor right yes yes yes yes you were
driven how driven i was when i was when
i was nine years old i actually got a
phone book myself and called an agency
in kentucky where i'm from a small town
ten thousand people you're in kentucky
and you've got a phone book kids don't
even know what a phone book is anymore
yeah exactly yeah chance of this photo
uh but you you got out a phone book and
you looked up an agent it looks like
talent agency or acting modeling agency
and uh i called them and they were like
hi um we need to speak to an adult um so
i was like begging my parents and
finally my mom and dad were like well
jesus he's making phone calls on his own
so we gotta you know we gotta do
something about this so they got behind
me and then i got the local agency and
eventually drove across the country to
come out here to the magical land of
glendale where i was staying in a motel
um and and started auditioning so it was
pretty pretty pretty crazy and you were
like your first desire was maybe not
even to be so much an actor as you want
to be in a boy band didn't you yeah i
did um i was a big instinct fan and uh i
had my hair dyed blonde like the frosted
tips in the 90s and uh we memorized that
we all did that we all did that okay i
thought it wasn't the only one um but
yeah so i literally i memorized all the
dance moves to every single song they
were made who was your in in sync
justin timberlake who who wouldn't want
to be justin timberlake i mean the guys
yeah he's
gorgeous we all know that uh talented
and at the time i was very
impressionable and i wanted to be a
young justin timberlake right so that so
you decided that's what i'm gonna be did
you have did you have the moves down i
mean could you sing did you have the
moves could not sing horrible singer but
i thought there were ways around that
possibly um but yeah i knew all the
dancers i could do the dance i was
actually i took some like hip-hop
classes and some break dancing i could
do like the worm and all that and then
why is that the worm is the one where
you jump on the ground yeah you like the
whole worm it's a worm like motion on
the grass okay that's the name what's
the name of the worm exactly um but yeah
the last time i tried it actually was
you know like about a year or so ago i
was like hey what if i could still do
this and i hit him into the worm and it
was more like a board it was like a bam
and i i injured myself in some areas
that
could hurt the possibility of having
children at some point yeah yeah yeah no
one's supposed to do the worm after like
age 15. yeah i found that out yeah so no
more worms no my warm days are over